The first trailer for Spider-Man: Far From
Home was pretty amazing and spectacular...but
it was also stuffed with more MCU and Marvel
Comics tidbits than you can shake a spider-stick
at.
Here are even more small details you may have
missed in the Far From Home trailer.
As excited as they are for all things MCU,
plenty of fans are still kind of annoyed that
Far From Home's trailer has revealed that
so many characters are alive — before we
get to see what happens in the fight against
Thanos in the Avengers: Endgame.
Well...whatever, dude.
The trailer reveals that Cobie Smulders is
back in the role of Nick Fury's Number 2,
Maria Hill.
What'll she be up to in Spider-Man's side
of the MCU?
Probably fighting giant sand monsters, for
starters.
At the very least, we know that whatever the
Avengers do to win the day in Endgame, Hill
has been un-dusted, right along with Nick
Fury and Spidey himself.
One encouraging detail in the Far From Home
trailer happens before Peter leaves New York
City.
Before heading out on his trip, he pays a
visit to the new bodega location of the friendly
Mr. Delmar, whose original store he inadvertently
helped destroy while thwarting a high-tech
ATM robbery in Homecoming.
"Mister Delmar…"
While he's still the same kindly neighborhood
grocer we saw he was in the first movie, Delmar
clearly hasn't forgotten about the violent
destruction of his original store — and
for whatever reason, he doesn't want his customers
to forget, either.
Up above the register, he's saved some framed
newspapers with headlines and photos about
the incident, including a framed photo of
him doing "go-web-go" hands next to Spider-Man.
Not a bad souvenir...
While out sightseeing in London, the students
face an attack while in traffic on the Tower
Bridge.
As lightning strikes all around them, Peter's
classmates sprint between buses and cars to
find safety.
As they do, we can see a license plate on
a bus that partially reads "MYS" — which
certainly seems like it refers to the movie's
probable villain, Mysterio.
On the back of a nice, shiny Audi, another
license plate reads "2865 SEP."
Now, remember the "Asm 212" we spotted in
Venice, which likely pointed to Hydro-Man's
first appearance in Amazing Spider-Man #212?
Well, this license plate seems to reference
another villain's first appearance: specifically
September 1965's Amazing Spider-Man #28: the
debut appearance of the Spidey villain Molten
Man, who we seem to have glimpsed at a different
point in the trailer.
Think we're done with secret license plate
messages?
Think again.
Sandblasted
When the giant sand monster rises up to fight
Nick Fury and Maria Hill, we can see the first
three digits of yet another car's license
plate.
The visible portion of the plate reads "463."
That seems to reference Amazing Spider-Man
#4, published in September 1963, and which
featured the introduction of the classic Spidey
character Sandman.
We've seen Sandman in the movies before—
he appeared as one of several bad guys in
Spider-Man 3, played by Thomas Haden Church.
How will this version of Spidey's sandy scoundrel
differ from the one we've seen before?
We'll know for sure on July 5.
Enough with the license plates, right?
Spider-Man: ​Far From Home​ manages yet
another stylish shout-out in its first trailer,
this time specifically for classic Spidey
writer J.M. DeMatteis, who gets a hotel in
Venice​ named after him.
For those who don't know, DeMatteis worked
with most of the major comic book companies,
including writing over 300 issues with Marvel
Comics​ alone.
He's responsible for writing some or all of
the most significant Spider-Man stories, including
"Maximum Carnage," the Harry Osborn/Green
Goblin-centric "The Child Within," and perhaps
most notably, "Kraven's Last Hunt."
During the opening scenes of the US version
of the Far From Home trailer, Peter watches
as Happy Hogan and Aunt May awkwardly flirt
with each other:
"You look nice.”
“Thank you.
You too.
“New dress?
Yeah.. how’d you know?"
"what just happened?"
What seems to have just happened is that Happy
and May might already be dating at this point
in the movie's story...having kept the whole
thing something of a secret from Peter up
until now.
The line of dialogue that really sets off
sirens for that potential plot development
is when Happy compliments May's new dress...but
won't say how he knows it's new in front of
Peter.
It feels like the only way for him to know
the details of May's wardrobe would be if
they were spending a lot of time together,
socially...without Peter knowing.
In the past, Tony Stark was always the flirty
one when it came to Aunt May.
"It's so hard for me to believe that you are
someone’s aunt.
“Yeah, well we come in all shapes and sizes,
you know.”
“This woman’s meatloaf is exceptional."
"just stop you there."
But as it turns out, May might have been single
and looking — looking past Tony, and apparently
right at the guy who does all of Stark's gruntwork.
If true — good going, dude.
"I have to tell you, not a fan of that Tony
Stark."
While the students are resting up at their
hotel after Mysterio steps in to save Venice,
you can see a small sticker on the lid of
Ned's laptop, featuring a picture from a popular
webcomic that you may remember going viral
in 2016.
In case you don't recognize the small sticker,
it's the "'This is Fine' dog," from a widely
shared installment in the series Gunshow by
artist KC Green.
The comic, which is basically about being
oblivious and cheerful while your house burns
down around you, also embraces a philosophy
that we feel would really come in handy if
we lived in the constantly besieged world
of the MCU.
Despite all the frequent disasters and threats
of annihilation, it still manages to seem
like a pretty fun place to live.
Dark Elves want to dominate the Nine Realms?
This is fine.
Scarlet Witch blew up a building, sparking
several international incidents?
This is fine!
The Far From Home trailer kind of sort of
spoiled some parts of Avengers Endgame?
That's… well, that's not ideal.
But it's fine!
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Spider-Man
and the MCU are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.